[Música]
ah
un tema recurrente en nuestro país y en
américa latina es la pobreza la pobreza
entra a los hogares y se manifiesta
sobre todo en la escasez de alimento en
las mesas
nosotros somos seres vivos y como tales
la naturaleza nos otorga sol oxígeno
agua y alimento al igual que el resto de
organismos con los cuales compartimos el
planeta
la modernidad y la tecnología nos han
facilitado las formas en las que llega
el alimento a nuestra mesa hoy todos nos
alimentamos de góndola es el mercado el
que nos diseña la dieta con propuestas
no del todo saludables restringidos en
la variedad y con un alto porcentaje de
procesados elaborados con sal aceites
y grasas y harinas basta mirar la parte
de atrás de un envase para darnos cuenta
que muchas veces nos alimentamos con
comida que no es lo que dice ser bebemos
un jugo que no tiene jugo tomamos una
leche que no es leche hasta un queso que
no tiene queso son tan pobres estos
procesados que muchas veces vemos que
están adicionados enriquecidos
coloreados saborizados nos hemos
acostumbrado a comer comida sabor otra
cosa una especie de comida simulada le
podríamos decir y en la actualidad
existe justamente una simulación tan
delirante que podríamos tener en nuestra
mesa un procesado sabor asado algo que
nunca nunca nunca va a poder reemplazar
una verdadera porción de asado pero
volvamos a la naturaleza
nosotros vivimos en un lugar
privilegiado una especie de embudo
geográfico en el cual convergen cientos
y cientos de especies de animales y
vegetales muchas de ellas comestibles a
través de los corredores biológicos
vivimos en una región que se llama
neotrópico una vasta región que se
expande desde méxico hasta la patagonia
dentro de esa región distintas
provincias finitos geográficas nos
comparten diversidad la amazonia el gran
chaco la mata atlántica y nos comparten
justamente cientos de especies a través
de un gran sistema circulatorio como es
la cuenca del plata
las comunidades originarias han
alimentado por cientos y miles de años
desde la misma aparición de la especie a
sus familias con esta diversidad es más
nuestros abuelos se alimentaban de la
naturaleza y qué pasó con nosotros qué
pasó que hemos dejado de lado cientos de
años de medicina natural y alimentos y
nos hemos dejado convencer de que esos
son malezas
es quizás la palabra malezas la trampa
lingüística con la cual el mercado nos
manipula para alejarnos de saberes y
sabores naturales porque piensen ustedes
quien le dan malezas a sus hijos muy por
el contrario las malezas se combaten se
exterminan se eliminan las malezas son
el argumento justo que tiene el mercado
para envenenar nos con agrotóxicos la
comida el suelo el aire y el agua
y dejarnos sobre todo rehenes del
mercado rehenes de las góndolas pero no
todo está perdido en un trabajo de
reconexión con esto de que somos seres
vivos un trabajo de reconexión con la
naturaleza nosotros proponemos rescatar
el valor comida que tienen las especies
silvestres fue un biólogo argentino
eduardo rata por de la universidad del
comahue quien a través de sus trabajos
fue el pionero que determinó la
potencialidad que tenían las especies
silvestres de su entorno en uno de sus
trabajos determinó que el 25 por ciento
de las especies que él tenía a su
alrededor tenían potencialidad de ser
alimento
en uno de sus trabajos cambiando título
malezas comestibles algo como medio
contradictorio el título de su obra él
mismo se encargó después de rebautizar
lo buen esas combustibles lo hizo en la
actualidad un biólogo brasileño un
seguidor como se ve como se dice ahora
de rapa por baldelli ferreira quina es
el autor de las siglas punks plantas
alimenticias no convencionales en un
estudio que le llevó más de 10 años él
determinó que hay más de 30 mil especies
que tienen partes que pueden ser
considerada alimento un número más que
impactante si nos damos cuenta que el
mercado a lo sumo nos propone 2030
especies en nuestra propuesta de
justamente rescatar el valor comida
nosotros proponemos a ser preparados
convencionales pero con silvestres
comestibles la tarta de la vereda es un
ejemplo es una tarta común si ustedes la
ven pero en realidad está hecha con
verdes que pueden estar
un monte en un pastizal en la plaza o en
la vereda de nuestra casa diente de león
llantén hasta las hojas del árbol de
mora pueden suplir esos verdes que nos
propone el mercado en un diseño propio
de la naturaleza cientos de especies
como las tunas las pitan gas por ejemplo
se pueden preparar dulces licores
comidas abundantes y nutritivas en ese
diseño que nos propone la naturaleza
dentro de esa propuesta yo les voy a
mostrar una justamente la casilla negra
es ésta chaucha que está acá la casilla
negra
viene navegando igual que las otras
especies que vienen por el sistema
hídrico pero la diferencia justamente es
que
es invasora invasora dicen los
científicos e invasora agresiva y como
invasora agresiva que es le roba
espacios a kurt pies ya 6 bosh existen
planes del gobierno para erradicar la y
está bien pero hay un detalle es
comestible se pueden hacer harinas
panificados con ella justamente este pan
está hecho con acacia negra se hacen
también licores dulces
y es más hasta con su residuos se puede
hacer un cigarro que se puede fumar y es
mucho más
no voy a decir nutritivo pero menos
nocivo que ese que propone el mercado
la naturaleza tiene inmensidad de
tesoros que todavía no conocemos y
necesitamos reconectarnos esa planta que
está ahí violeta está en la casa de
todas las abuelas crece sola verdad
nadie sabe que se come se hace un buen
aderezo con ella porque en realidad las
plantas no han evolucionado hasta aquí
para adornar nuestras nuestros jardines
o nuestras plazas
las plantas tienen funciones lógicas y
una de ellas es la de alimentarnos para
dejarlos con la idea les voy a les voy a
decir una copla como para ir suavizando
el mensaje que voy a dar en esta vida
moderna el estrés por ahí a los varones
les puede dar una mala pasada y no
pueden estar a la altura de las
circunstancias entonces yo les digo
óigame usted compañero si de casualidad
el estrés lo ha poca y no puede estar a
la altura no sea cabeza dura que la
pacha le da una solución meta le un
abrojito al mate para levantar esa
desilusión
[Música]
y
o
i
ah
[Música]